IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
"NICE CAT, MEAN CAT."
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
CATS. PEOPLE LOVE THEM.
BUT CATS ARE UNPREDICTABLE
CREATURES.
THEY CAN GO FROM SNUGGLY TO
HORRIBLE AT THE DROP OF A HAT.
FOR SEEMINGLY NO REASON.
KIND OF LIKE THAT GIRL YOU DATED
IN COLLEGE THAT YOU SWORE YOU
COULD FIX. OH!
I CAN MAKE HER LOVE ME.
I CAN ABSORB ALL OF HER
PROBLEMS. SHE'S SCRATCHINGME!
I'M IN ECSTASY.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A STILL FROM A GIF OR A VIDEO
AND FOR 250 POINTS, YOU TELL ME
IF THIS CAT IS NICE CAT OR A
MEAN, HELL-BEAST CAT.
FIRST ONE, FIRST ONE. THIS
TV-READY KITTY.
IS THIS IS A NICE CAT OR AN
ASSHOLE. RANDY?
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
ASSHOLE.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, LET'S FIND
OUT.
>> THIS LITTLE GUY IS HAVING
FUN, BUT PART OF THE SENTENCE,
THE COUPLE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
COME RIGHT.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> CAT FIGHT.
>> CHRIS: I WONDER IF THE
WEATHER GIRL IS WATCHING, THAT'S
RIGHT, BITCH.
TRY TO TAKE MY JOB.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE. THIS
CAT-IN-THE-HATE AND HIS
OFF-SCREEN FRIEND?
OH, HOW COULD THAT? -- I
MEAN, COME ON. JASON
>> OH, THIS IS AN ASSHOLE.
>> CHRIS: YOU THINK SO?
>> YEAH, I THINK THIS ONE'S
GONNA GET -- I CAN FEEL IT.
I KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE, BUT I WAS
JUST HOPING.
(AUDIENCE SAYS WHOA !)
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: I CAN TELL YOU
SOMETHING?
THIS IS ACTUALLY-- THAT'S
ACTUALLY MY FRIEND TIM'S CAT.
I SWEAR TO GOD.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS CHRIS
BROWN'S CAT.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> THE PROBLEM IS, YOU KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PACK
TOGETHER TOMORROW.
>> WHERE DO YOU GO SHOPPING FOR
A BOWLER HAT THAT SMALL?
A HIPSTER HAT --I WOULD HAVE
SMACKED ( BLEEP ) OUT OF THAT
CAT, TOO. LOOK AT THAT HAT!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: THE CAT'S FINE,
PROBABLY!
NEXT ONE, THIS DOG-LOVING CAT.
THIS DOG-LOVING CAT.
JASON?
>> OH, THIS IS GOING TO END
HORRIBLY.
>> CHRIS: YOU THINK SO?
>> YES, THIS IS GOING TO BE
HORRIBLE.
>> CHRIS: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> HELLO, YOUNG LADY.
>> IT LOOK LIKES -- OH!
>> THAT COULD GO EITHER WAY, BY
THE WAY.
>> WHY IS THAT A FUNNY CAT?
THAT'S NOT A FUNNY CAT.
IT'S A TWISTED CAT.
>> I WOULD TITLE THIS THING
ASPCA OFFICE PARTY GOES WRONG.
( APPLAUSE )